has
oh
is
mojitos
oh
what else do i have to say
together
react redux
anymore
together
good afternoon ndc
everybody stand up
all right
so remain standing if you build or have
ever built apis that use http
so if you've never built any web
services at all sit down okay remain
standing if you've ever implemented
server support for http put
remain standing if you've implemented
patch
remain standing if you've ever used
content negotiation to avoid something
that would have been a breaking change
and upset your customers
congratulations you people are the lucky
winners i'll buy you a drink later hello
yes welcome my name is dylan beatty
and for the next hour i am going to talk
to you about rest
um
so little exercise there at the
beginning just to get some idea of you
know the level of the room and who's
done what and stuff and yeah it's pretty
good most of you clearly you understand
the principles of http uh you understand
some of the patterns you understand what
patches even if you've not necessarily
worked with it and stuff um rest is
a massive buzzword rest is very very
widely used um hands up anybody who has
ever
talked to a vendor and they've gone oh
yeah we have a restful api and you look
at it and you're like no you really
don't you you think you do but yeah
um so what we're going to do this
afternoon is i'm going to take you
through some of the sort of
the bits of rest that go beyond just
http get and post and put and actually
look at some of the the architectural
constraints and the styles which
create or which inform the design of
restful systems
rest is not necessarily good
there can be restful systems which are
bad systems and there are systems which
are very very good systems which have
nothing to do with rest
one of the key things to understand you
know one of the things that i try and do
with these talks is to make sure at
least people understand what we mean by
what is a restful api and what is not
there is no intrinsic value judgment in
whether rest is the right thing for you
for your team for your company for what
you are trying to achieve your customers
but if we don't understand the
distinction between restful systems and
other systems you can't have a informed
discussion about it you can't make an
informed decision about it
very quick recap
this is roy roy fielding um roy fielding
was
at cern roy fielding worked on the http
1.1 spec roy fielding worked on
the original httpd and apache web
servers he's now the chief scientist at
adobe
and rest was
a architectural style that was published
in his phd thesis
as phd thesis theses thesis go it is
actually very readable it's on his
website i thoroughly recommend if you're
interested in understanding where these
ideas came from and the kind of
rationale and the thinking behind them
check it out read it it's good there's
some really really good stuff good
reasoning good examples good discussion
in there
and what he basically says is
this when given a name a coordinated set
of architectural constraints becomes a
style roy fielding's thinking was very
heavily informed by
architecture in the sense of
construction buildings you know walking
around downtown sydney yesterday there
is some astonishing wonderful
architecture here and in architecture we
have styles you have rococo you have
barack you have brutalism you have
classical you have all these things and
they are not tools and they are not
frameworks and they are not plugins and
they are not modules they are styles it
is a
a set of patterns for thinking about how
to solve certain recurring problems
rest is not something that you download
and install from npm or nougat rest is a
way of thinking about how the systems
you are building are going to evolve
over time and this is one of the key
things to bear in mind about it
this is a direct quote from the person
who coined rest and he says rest is
software design on a scale of decades
every detail is intended to promote
software longevity and independent
evolution many of the constraints are
directly opposed to short-term
efficiency
if you are in a hurry
if you are trying to ship version one
before you run out of funding if you are
trying to hit a deadline if you are
trying to fix an urgent problem that is
happening in production
you should probably not be trying to
build a restful system those are not the
situations where rest is the right
answer to your problem
the other thing about this it's on a
scale of decades roy fielding published
his phd thesis 15 years ago we have not
had decades yet we've had one and a half
decades that's not long enough really to
know whether he was right
but
there is a lot of thinking that suggests
that many of the patterns that he
outlined are actually they are good ways
of building flexible software which can
evolve over a long long period of time
you know we are rest is about trying to
design systems which will run for
decades you know anyone here actually
got code there running that's more than
10 years old
i know i do go classic asp
the framework that never dies
but you know it is it's this interesting
think about what it is that you're doing
what is the value you're trying to
deliver you're trying to delight a
customer are you trying to hit a
deadline are you trying to comply with
some new legislation
and if those requirements
genuinely inform building a system which
you want to be able to evolve over not
necessarily decades but you know years
then it's worth really understanding
taking the time to understand these
patterns and then making an informed
decision as to whether they are the
right patterns for what you are trying
to do
rest outlines a set of constraints
around how software systems are built
it's interesting to note that rest does
not say you must use http it doesn't say
you must use xml it doesn't say you must
use json
it defines a set of patterns for
communications between a client and a
server
and a ways of facilitating those
interactions in those conversations
client server should not be terribly
surprising to anybody in this room you
have a client or lots of clients we've
probably all got them in our pockets
these things the clients some of these
things are servers as well because
they're getting quite clever now
but you have a server which has
centralized data logic behavior rules
information you have a bunch of clients
connecting to it this helps in a lot of
ways if you need to fix something you
don't need to mail out cds like everyone
had to in the 1980s you just go bang
we've deployed a new release to our
server now all of our customers got the
benefit of that new release
statelessness is one of the key tenets
of being able to scale systems easily
it's also one of the things that
everybody
kind of got wrong almost as soon as the
web was invented has anyone been through
the process of taking something like
asp.net or php and try to put it behind
a load balancer and suddenly you realize
that things are breaking because your
code uses something called session
yeah so
http comes along and rest is a set of
stars on top and they're like oh don't
don't have state you know every
conversation between a client and a
server should be an atomic transaction
the client should say this is me here
are my credentials here is all of the
information that i need to give to you
and the server
the http server in this context should
be able to say okay we can deal with
that the second during introduced
session you're relying on your web
server to remember who was here a minute
ago you've got all these little
half-finished conversations and
half-baked transactions hanging around
in memory one you could do better things
with that memory
two you don't know whether anyone is
ever going to come back and finish those
conversations so you have to think well
do i want my session timeout to be set
to an hour do i want my session timeout
set to five minutes and three if one of
your servers in your farm dies you need
to bounce someone onto another one it's
gonna die because all of that state has
disappeared with the server that has
just gone down
so try and avoid state you know if you
have session your system's not restful
might be a perfectly good system you
know it might be the right solution to
your problem but it's not restful
cachable
cache ability is is particularly
relevant out here in australia where
there are four fiber optic cables
connecting us to the rest of the world
in a perfect world
when they release a new version of
jquery that will get downloaded to
australia once
and then will be cached locally and
everyone else in the entire nation of
australia who needs jquery 2.1 will get
the same one instead of reusing the very
valuable contended bandwidth cache
ability there's basically two ways of
caching that matter in restful systems
infinite and never
optimize for infinity
when you put a resource on the web
try if you possibly can to make sure
that anyone who's ever seen that
resource that url
before
can use the version they got last week
or last year or the version that someone
else got that their isp is caching or
their cellular data provider is caching
when you start thinking about it in
terms of you know cache for three hours
six hours no no think about it never in
infinity and optimize for infinity it
really starts to inform the way you
think about the information you're
presenting how you structure your urls
layered system goes very very closely
hand in hand with cachability it's the
idea you have a client a server
and actually the client doesn't care
whether it's talking to the server or
it's talking to a proxy that's talking
to a load balancer that's talking to a
server or it's talking to a proxy that's
talking to something else it's talking
to a vpn that's talking to a file
at every level any element in that stack
should talk to the thing above and the
thing below and it shouldn't care what's
hidden behind those
this allows you to do things like
so a good example of this is using
reverse proxies on things like your
build pipeline when you're downloading
packages from nuget or from npm stick a
proxy in front of it and then if you've
ever downloaded anything you'll have a
local copy of it nuget doesn't need to
know that that's happened your build
server doesn't need to know that that's
happened the upstream servers have no
idea that you're caching stuff because
each of these layers provides an
abstraction between the relying system
and the providing system the server
code on demand is the ability to say the
servers i got a whole bunch of stuff i
got logic i've got data i've got
behavior
i'm assuming most of you are in scott
hanselman's keynote this morning where
he's talking about you know this idea
you've got 10 vms running in a cluster
and you've got 1000 users now actually
now you have
1010 machines
involved in your infrastructure because
all of your clients have got machines of
their own which have computing power
they have memory they have storage they
have capability code on demand is what
makes this happen code on demand is why
gmail kicked hotmail's ass so
resoundingly because gmail came along
and they're like actually we are not
going to round trip every mouse click
back to our server and send it back
again we're going to run your mail
system on your computer and we're only
going to talk to the server when we
actually need some information we're not
going to just use it as part of
navigation
and that you know code on demand is just
javascript and the assembly language of
the web this thing has taken off
massively in terms of
browser experiences
there's not so much yet in terms of apis
you know most people are still quite
wary of getting arbitrary code on an api
response and then running it
um
have you ever i was installing homebrew
on my mac yesterday and it's like paste
this shell script into an administrator
terminal window and i'm like uh
no
i'm not entirely sure i want to do that
so you go and you dig the bits around so
there are elements of trust and there's
some security patterns we're going to
look at later which facilitate these
kinds of interactions
uniform interface anything you can do
over
http as an example of this
is done using the same thing you have a
verb get put post options head patch
you have a content type you have a bunch
of headers you have a payload body
request body response
it's the same for all of them if you
want to interact with a png or a piece
of video or something you do not need to
switch to a different protocol on a
different set of conventions the same
interface is used to interact with
different media types being provided by
different systems it's one of the
reasons the web works you know one of
the reasons why the web is better than
you had the aol client to get on the aol
network to talk to other aol users and
if you wanted to talk to someone on
compuserve you couldn't because they
were all these little walled gardens
and finally the one which we're
basically talking about for the rest of
the day hypermedia is the engine of
application state which i'm not going to
explain now we're going to talk about
that in depth
this bit is optional
in
the thesis in which rest is described he
explicitly says code on demand's
optional you know that bit you can do it
or you cannot do it
all of the rest of them
that's what rest is
if your system has these problems and it
embraces these patterns and principles
in order to solve them you can
legitimately say that you have a restful
system you don't necessarily need all of
them you may have very very small
systems where actually there's very
little notion of application state and
so you haven't got hyper media yet
but as your system grows and you start
encountering the problems that we're
going to look at today
if hypermedia is the solution you adopt
then you're restful if hypermedia you
decide is too complicated then you're
not restful it doesn't matter you might
still be fine system might work you know
ship it everyone gets paid customers are
delighted
rest is not magic it's just one more way
of doing things and the more we
understand about it the better informed
decisions we can make about whether it's
the right solution for what we're doing
so
we're going to build a social network
and we're going to build a social
network for superheroes because all the
social networks that we've got at the
moment are all based on the idea of
people having friends i want to build a
social network where you can have
enemies so you can you know assign
people and you can have battles and then
we can sell the film rights for billions
of dollars because you know you think
software's big bucks look at what marvel
are doing in hollywood right now
so and we're not interested in front-end
stuff we're just building a back-end
we're going to build a persistent system
we're going to put an api in front of it
and we're going to publish our api
specification and the world is going to
come knocking flocking to our doorstep
and is going to embrace our social
network
and we're going to start with this
we're going to start with a end point a
resource called profiles
this is a collection of profiles because
you've got to have profiles because it's
a social network
and we are going to seed it with some
test data and the first person in our
network is going to be tony stark who
has chosen the username ironman for
obvious reasons
we've got some data
at this point
we've got a pretty good restful solution
to an incredibly small problem that
isn't actually very interesting so let's
extend it a little bit let's create a
way that people can join our social
network by posting their own data to our
endpoint
so now we've got post slash profiles
hands up anyone who has ever argued with
that team for more than say four hours
about what http post actually means
the rest of the verbs are pretty simple
yep get me that put replace that with
this
uh delete remove that post is
complicated because post can have side
effects posts can be used for things
which are not idempotent things that it
might be safe to do once and dangerous
to do twice
and so there's a lot of specific
validation and semantics about the way
you implement post so all we've got here
is we've got an endpoint that you take
some data you wrap it up as json post it
to that endpoint and it's going to give
you back
bang 201 created
and it's going to say location there
so what this is effectively said you're
giving me some data i've accepted it i
have created a resource for you
here is where you can find that resource
and then as a convenience we're actually
going to include the resource that was
just created in the payload and the
response to save you having to do a
round trip
and this is brilliant you know iron man
goes and tells all his mates about it
and spider-man tells all his mates about
it and we get up in the morning and two
million people have joined our social
network by posting their own stuff in
jason we've got everyone down as far as
howard the duck you know we've got
obscure superheroes no one's ever heard
of from that one comic book special
edition in 1962.
and then
the phone rings
and it's the network team and they're
like your api is using all of our
bandwidth we're doing fine yesterday and
now the entire continent of australia
can't get online because your api is
consuming all of it
and someone else says your stupid api is
overloading our database
the reason this is happening is because
we've got a resource called profiles and
when there was one person in that list
you could get it and it was fine two
three four five people
two million people every time anyone
goes get profiles they are retrieving
two million records every time they do
it
this is clearly not a terribly good idea
because it is going to clobber the
bandwidth it's going to club a database
it's going to waste an awful lot of
resources we want a more elegant
solution to this so someone comes up
with a bright idea hey why don't we why
don't we just do pagination so we'll
split it down into pages and we'll have
page one page two page three
and we think yeah brilliant you know
nice idea okay so
get profiles page one
bang there's some stuff
and if you need more than that you can
go in and you can go okay get me page
two page three page four page five
this looks pretty simple you know it's
easy to understand
at this point we have stopped being
restful
it works but it's not rest the reason it
is not rest is that at this point that
knowledge that understanding that page
number starts at one and goes two three
four five
that's state
that's understanding the transitions
that are available from a particular
point in our application
and we have not defined anywhere within
our resources how that state exists to
know that we support page one two three
four five you're gonna have to look on
the wiki or read the manual or
file a support ticket or something
and we don't want that because we want
our api itself to be
explorable
so
anyone recognize these
one person two people three people four
five six
i grew up on these these are choose your
own adventure books these are brilliant
so you open page one and it outlines the
scenario and then yeah so let's let's
actually have a look so here's an
example
so this is the ndc sydney choose your
own adventure
it's tuesday night you've just arrived
in sydney you've been traveling for 29
straight hours and your brain thinks
it's half past breakfast time yesterday
you should probably get some sleep but
there's talk of heading downtown to
scruffy murphy's for drinks
and niall is going on about this amazing
whiskey bar he found down some dodgy
back alley
and now we have to make a choice
to go to our room and take a nap turn to
page 74
to go to scruffy murphy's for a beer
page 23 and if you want to go and drink
single malt with nile until your visa
card stops working go to page 41.
so control hands who's going for a nap
scruffy murphy's
whiskey bar
good choice
this is a really great example of of
hyper media because what we've got here
is we have a resource representation
in a format that the consumer can
understand
and attach to that resource
representation we have all the
information we need to understand what
can we do from here what are the options
where can we go what avenues of
exploration are open to us having
retrieved this resource
so let's go back to our
endpoint our profiles endpoint and let's
instead of using page one two three four
let's actually put some hypermedia
representation in
now
this particular example you'll notice
the bits in yellow are effectively the
things that have changed so one our
content type is not json anymore it's
hal plus json
the way content types work
the application bit is standard you can
put anything you like before the plus
the bit after the plus is standard so
what we're doing here is we're saying
we're going to extend the basic json
data type with something called hal
media application language which is one
of several javascript multimedia uh
hyper media formats that we'll look at
in a second
i like hal because it's quite compact
and it's human readable and for these
kind of examples it's succinct and it's
nice it works well
so what hal does is it says okay
we are going to one the data itself
we're going to wrap up in a collection
here called items
and we are going to add a collection
called links anything in these examples
with an underscore as part of the house
specification
anything else is my own stuff things
that we've added to demonstrate how this
works so now when we get slash profiles
we get this little payload that says
okay here's where you can go from here
we've got a self link if you want the
same thing again this is the url you go
to
the next page is available here
the last page we have this wonderful
hashing problem in english the word last
can either mean like the one before this
one or it can mean the last one in the
list
so i should have fixed this what i tend
to do is i use previous and i use final
in
system so that we avoid the word last
completely
so we basically said so the final page
here is is index 220 there are five
items in this list your list is index 0
in a collection of 223
and here's the stuff you wanted
and this is pretty cool it's easy it's
readable you can look at that and you or
more correctly your api client can go
all right let's open the links
collection and see if next exists if it
does we know we're not at the end when
we get to the end of the list next we'll
come back as it won't even be there
okay fine we've got the entire list
whether we're storing that locally or
caching it or we're just showing it in
some kind of a data grid or something
kind of doesn't matter
so that's the first example of using
hypermedia to
inform clients how they can interact
with the system we've got
now the nice thing one of the reasons
why hypermedia gives you this
flexibility the client does not have to
know that we are doing page one two
three or index zero five ten if we
decide that actually we're gonna start
doing things alphabetically the client
all the client needs to know is to go
into the links collection find next and
retrieve whatever that is
next is a convention that's part of our
system lynx is a convention that's part
of hal
href is a convention that's part of how
hypermedia json works but the url itself
the client should not know it should not
care it should retrieve it it should
follow it it should request the next one
we can switch to doing pagination
alphabetically we can switch to doing it
by which shard in our cluster that
indexes are stored on we can do all
sorts of things with it without breaking
the client application because the
client is following those links instead
of having some hard baked behavior that
someone wrote after reading about it on
a wiki
so
social network let's start with friends
we can we can look at adding enemies
later so
we've added we got a username we've got
name we're going to add friends to it
we've got username we got username we
got username we've got collections of
friends
and because this is a social network and
you want to be able to stalk people and
see what they're doing we're going to
add updates
so tony stark has gone on and he said
hey i'm working on a new iron man suit
and then a little while later he has
this brilliant idea he's going to build
an iron man suit with a selfie stick on
it so he can take photographs of himself
out saving the world and then a little
while later he says oh no the selfie
stick broke oh well
back to the drawing board
so we got friends and we got updates but
of course the friends can have updates
and the friends can have friends
and the friends friends can have updates
this by the way is what they call big
data this is when the json won't fit on
a powerpoint slide anymore
we have a problem
because the phone is about to ring again
or you know something's going to pop up
on hip chat or or slack
and someone is going to say your stupid
api is using all of our bandwidth again
and someone's going to say your api is
overloading the database again i told
you we should have stuck to php we never
had these problems with php
what we've basically done is we've built
a degenerate system because
when you request one person
it's going to bring you back all their
friends and all their updates and all
their friends friends and all their
friends friends friends and so there is
no way to say please get me one profile
and please do not bring back the entire
connected graph for this whole social
network
so
what we want to do is to break the
resource down instead of this huge tree
that you start at the top and you get
the whole thing you know it's everything
or burst
we're going to use the same hypermedia
principle to break this profile down
into lots of little granular bits of
data
so same thing hal json we're getting
iron man's profile
links we've got self we got friends we
got photos we got updates
so we can retrieve this
and again we have an api client that
goes in there we need to tell it this is
friends this is photos this is updates
those things ideally won't change it's
part of the contract between our server
and our consumers but the url formats
don't matter we can move friends onto a
whole separate infrastructure we can do
the rest on aws and friends on azure if
we want to because the client just knows
how to follow the urls and it doesn't
care what those urls are because that's
the backbone of this kind of hypermedia
stuff
and this looks pretty cool and so now
someone's building an api client and
they go yeah profiles brilliant
okay let's get friends
okay let's get updates okay let's get
photos oh yeah let's get photo number
one two three four oh photo one two
three four's got some comments let's get
those
let's get photo one three four five oh
and that one's got some comments
let's go photo one four five six
and then this happens the phone rings
again
or slack or hip chat or twitter or skype
and so i was like dude your api is crazy
i just want to draw a profile i've got
to make like 50 calls
and then your ops team ring up and
they're like our web server just crashed
because the iis logs have filled up the
c drive
you ever had this happen in production
yeah
something that used to be one http
request is now 50 requests and every one
of those requests is going to write
something to see inet pub log files and
they were like well of course we put all
the applications on the d drive but we
didn't think we had to move the logs
because this never happened before
and of course we never had this problem
with php
so
we've gone from massive two gigs of data
that is dreadful because every time
anyone tries to request anything it
overloads the network to tiny little
pieces of data that are overloading the
network because you have to make like 50
calls in order to do anything
this is one of the absolute key things
where rest doesn't make a whole lot of
sense until you know what words to
google and the magic words to google are
resource expansion
once you know that that's what you're
looking for you will find a wealth of
very good information about how to do
this if you don't know that
particular phrase
you can stumble around for ages going
rest api too many requests rest api too
slow log files and
so that that's make a note of that one
because that's a really useful kind of
shibboleth to know to
go and look for more information about
this stuff later but what we're
effectively doing is something is very
analogous to the idea of eager loading
if you've ever worked with an orm it's
saying i want this but actually i know
what page i'm trying to draw or i know
what form i'm trying to populate i would
like to please get iron man's profile
and can you bring back the updates
in line bring back those as well
and so what we've got
this bit is ours we are free to create
this resource expansion however we like
in a way that works for our clients and
our servers
and hal basically says okay so we're
going to find the thing named updates
and then in the embedded payload we are
going to stick in a
json property called updates
which in this case is
effectively what we would have got by
making a second request only it's going
to make it for us and insert it into the
embedded thing
and you can do some quite sophisticated
stuff by supporting dot paths so you can
expand
updates.friend.username or
update.friend.photo
you can expand updates comma friends
comma photos
it may not necessarily work it's very
very good to think of this as
sort of a hint rather than a guaranteed
behavior because at some point you may
request so many expanded things that
your server
you make a conscious decision no if
someone asks for all that we're not
going to give them what they wanted
so one pattern that's useful for
implementing this is when you request
something
cache it locally with the url of the
resource remember we're optimizing here
for infinite caching so once you've got
something stick it in a cache until you
run out of memory and if you need that
thing again first thing you do is you
check your cache that doesn't work you
stick it in a resource expansion if
after the resource expansion the cache
is still empty then you go and you do
another request and you actually
explicitly fetch that thing so you have
this idea of you know trying different
layers in your architecture to see
whether you have a convenient handy copy
of that thing knocking around that you
can use
um let's quickly talk you through there
are
about half a dozen different
hyper media formats it's one of the the
things that
when
json was sort of first postulated this
idea of using javascript as a data
format instead of as a programming
language
one of the things that it doesn't
natively have is any notion of hyper
media so people have extended the
language in various ways i'm going to
talk you through these quickly we're not
going to go into a lot of detail it's
just worth knowing what they are if you
want to go away and google this stuff
later
um
jason ld is the
web standard one this is a w3c
standard that's been ratified
json ld is very much read-only it's
about navigating collections of data
that you're retrieving hydra extends
jsonld by telling you interactions and
actions that are available on those
resources
json api is another one which has got a
fair bit of traction
collection plus json
siren hal
json ld looks like this
so
the interesting thing to notice here
this is another one of those things
that's a bit confusing until you get it
these are real urls
there is a consortium of people
including facebook google microsoft
yahoo
apple who are basically trying to write
a definitive guide to everything
of how you represent machine readable
data about real things
and so what we've got here is
if you go there
it will actually explain what a name is
in the context of json ld and anyone who
implements this should use name to mean
the same thing so in this context
it's this wonderful kind of taxonomic
hierarchy the top level has got a thing
and then a you know a thing can be a
person and a person can be a film
director and a film director can be
something else and you have this very
very rich hierarchy of interactions and
behaviors but the point is if you
request anything from a json ld endpoint
that defines a name and an alternate
name you should be able to use those
things consistently both in the way you
build your applications and in the
discussions you can have about them
so we've got a thing here which has a
name it's got an alternate name and it's
got an image and the image has an id and
the id has a type and then down here
we've said okay so within the context of
this person the name is tony stark and
if you want to know what that means go
and look up here
alternate name is iron man and that's a
url to an image of this thing
once you click that schema.org is not
like example.com everything starts
making a lot more sense
hydra is this legible from the back i'm
aware that there's a fat chunk of code
on this so i won't dwell on it too long
basically hydra extends this by saying
okay so there is a supported operation
here
which um will allow you to
it expects a certain schema this is the
method it allows these are the status
codes you can expect to get back from it
and then down here we document the
get like the read-only interactions that
happen with that
collection json semantically fairly
similar to hal we got this idea of a
version we've got an href for the the
resource we've requested we've got a
collection of links
and then we have a collection of items
which sits in the same payload
this has an interesting example in that
the items themselves contain a nested
links collection to show you how you can
have hypermedia at the top level but you
can also have hypermedia relationships
with resources that are embedded in the
payload of the thing you've just
retrieved
json api
again similar solution to the same sort
of problem we've got the same collection
of links self next last and then in here
we've got collections of embedded data
types including relationships there is
some interesting semantics around what
things like author and comments mean in
the context of this which is worth
reading up on if this is a format you
want to use
siren is another one that allows you to
define as well as defining read-only
properties you can define actions so
what we've got in here is we've got a
resource we got here a mission list so
we've got one of our superheroes and we
want to send them off to do something
somewhere pull a bunch of data out
and here we've got an action so this is
what it's called title is interesting
because these are human readable this is
designed to be something that you can
theoretically render your user interface
based entirely on metadata that's been
provided in the
representation that you've retrieved
from the api
so we've got a bunch of fields here that
you need in order to send iron man off
on a mission you've got a type you've
got an endpoint href and you've got some
human readable commentary going with
that
like i said there's an awful lot to it
some of them are very similar some of
them are very different some of them are
standard some of them are not if you
want to do anything it's worth doing a
quick pass over all of them
one of the things you'll find is a bit
dizzy in particular if you're doing the
stuff in dot net is you've got one two
three four five different json hyper
media formats plus you've got a choice
between aspen mvc or web api or nancy or
open raster or service deck so to pick
the right one you need to look at like
30 35 different combinations of
technologies and stuff which is why i
love working in it so much there's just
so many standards to choose from
okay
let's enrich our api a little bit so
we're going to go back to profile we're
going to start adding a whole bunch more
data so we can get really really stalky
on people
so we are going to add
height weight location status hometown
email website birthday
last modified we've got all of this rich
information all this this great stuff on
there
now we want to go in and update it so
we're going to use an http put and we
are going to put to slash profiles http
1.1 that's our content type
and we're going to update the status
now
what we don't know
is that
iron man's wearing his apple watch and
his apple watch is linked into our
heroes network and as he's flying home
across the atlantic it is constantly
updating his location and posting it to
our network so by the time he's finished
composing this update the location is
out of date
so when he tries to do that status it's
going to say 409 conflict the thing you
sent me does not match the thing i've
got
now this is a problem you'll hit quite
often if you are using this idea of just
putting a profile put in http says
whatever is at this endpoint whether
there's something there or not replace
the whole thing with this new copy
so you have to provide the complete
representation of the latest version of
that resource
and the server will interpret that
either it'll just blindly replace it and
risk blowing away some data or it'll do
some complicated version checking
authentication it's up to you how that
gets implemented
but the signs that you're getting this
wrong are that you start getting these
kinds of support requests
someone's saying why do i need to put
the whole profile just to update
location you know this is crazy because
we're going to add more and more and
more fields to this thing and someone
else is saying every time i try and do
an update i get a four online conflict
because i can't actually retrieve update
and post back fast enough to keep up
with the changes that are being pushed
through the system
so there is one solution we can apply to
this and that's to break our resource
down into lots of tiny little endpoints
so instead of iron man's profile being a
resource we'll say what about if the
status element of that profile was a
resource and then we could put that on
its own
so we're going to put to profiles iron
man status finished saving the world i
need a drink and it's going to say 204
no content which basically means i got
this cool sorted fine
this works
you will very quickly find that you have
got dozens of tiny little resource
endpoints which are all gettable and
portable
and then you start getting into all the
complicated semantics because now you've
got all these different resources you
need a way of navigating them so you end
up with very very complicated links
collections and stuff what we want is a
better way of changing one element of a
composite resource
patch
this is from the rfc
specification rfc 5789 which
tells us how to implement patch
except it doesn't it tells us that patch
is
a way of doing this
but it doesn't actually provide very
much guidance at all on how you should
go about implementing it patch method
requests that a set of changes described
in a request be applied to the resource
the set of changes is represented in a
format called a patch document
identified by a media type so far so
good
this is the actual example from the rfc
of how you implement it
that's what they tell you this is how
you how you submit a patch
which is great because it means we are
free to do this however we like
so one completely standard compliant
implementation of patch is that we
download the profile we update it in our
favorite text editor we save it we use
the unix diff command to diff the old
thing and the new thing and spit out a
patch file
and then we upload the patch file using
patch with this custom content type of
application x unix diff
we upload the patch and the server goes
great i'm going to take that and i'm
going to use the patch command to apply
it to the resource and and yeah
everyone's fine happy
200 okay
there are better ways of doing it
there is a thing called json patch which
is a
format for representing a series of
changes it also includes some fairly
neat stuff around operators so jsonpatch
effectively gives you a array so it is
an ordered list of operations so in this
example what we are saying is
first of all we've got an http if match
header so we've got something that will
generate checksums and make sure that
the checksum the client's seen most
recently is the same as the one on the
server
then for a bit of extra resiliency
we're going to run an operation called
test we are going to go into this
profiles iron man which is a json
resource
and we are going to find the thing which
is at last modified
in that resource and we are going to
test that it is equal to this
if it is we are going to proceed to the
next operation in the list if it is not
we are going to return a 409 conflict
and bailout the next thing in the list
is a replace operation we're going to
find the thing at status and we're going
to say finished saving the world i need
a drink
okay
or
we could decide that we are going to
implement patch using memes of nicholas
cage
which is completely legitimate there's
nothing about this that defies the
standard you know we have a thing that
if you want us to do something
update your record update your email
address you have to go to
memegenerator.net and put it on a jpeg
of nic cage and then you've got to
upload that as a nic cage plus png and
what we're going to do is we're going to
print all those out and stick them on
someone's desk and we're going to return
202 accepted
which is seriously old school but is
still actually standards compliant
there was an interesting thing in
scott's keynote this morning where he
was talking about guys at intel they
have to send a fax to provision new
virtual machines i was thinking you
could actually
probably implement rest or restful
systems using fax machines as long as
you controlled what it was that was
written on the facts and what response
you could realistically expect because a
202 accepted is a kind of general
purpose
we are going to deal with this later
come back try again or you know we'll
notify you or start polling every 10
seconds to see if this thing's ready yet
so you could probably implement rest
using fax machines i wouldn't recommend
it
but it'd be fun to try if they can do
http over carrier pigeons we can do this
so
ceo comes down and he's like ah you know
someone is is they're looking to buy our
network and they need to make a couple
of changes to our data format
we need to expose full names and
surnames separately so that we can index
by surname so that they can feed it into
their crm system and also they want to
replace the hometown with an iso 3166
country code so we can do that cool
google maps visualization of where all
our users are
and you know it's friday it's kind of
late so we sit down yeah no problem so
we just go and we change the json format
and we break this up and we break
hometown down into a city and a country
code and then we push straight to
production because it's late and what
the hell integration tests are probably
all right maybe
and then when we log on later we have a
string of messages saying hey your api
has broken our application and our
website's stopped working none of our
reports work and you broke the internet
oops
we did
we didn't made a breaking change we
changed our format such that the clients
that are out there that are expecting
name to be one field are suddenly
finding a chunk of json the best thing
that's going to happen is they're going
to just treat that json as a string and
suddenly all our customers are going to
be called open brackets first name colon
tony comma surname colon start close
brackets
they're more likely to crash
catastrophically and they're going to do
this on every single resource because
we've changed the fundamental kind of
root level profile entry
so we need a way of being able to make
those kinds of changes
without disrupting people who are
already using them
easiest thing to do is never break
anything you know just get it all right
first time so have a big design meeting
and write down all the answers for the
next
20 years because rest is software design
on a scale of decades
you might be able to get away with not
breaking anything for a couple of months
but seriously if you're building systems
that are going to run for any serious
length of time things are going to
change and there are solutions to this
and the interesting thing there is how
do you decide which solution to adopt
because they are all wrong
there are three ways so a lot of this
stuff um is troy hunt wrote a great blog
post on this uh
two years ago now where on his have i
been punching he was rolling out version
two of some apis for that and he did
this great write-up of the different
patterns and there's some um sebastian
lambler is out there right now giving
talks about don't version your apis it's
evil you should do everything using
content negotiation which is kind of a
different approach to versioning so
there's a lot of interesting thinking
around this
so one way of doing it is that you have
a version one api and a version two api
and they're on different urls
so get version two
okay
get version one okay
this requires you to know when you do
version one that there's gonna be a
version two so you can put version one
in the url
so it doesn't downgrade particularly
gracefully
another way of doing it is
to use content negotiation so when your
client connects to your server the first
version probably says hey i speak json
just give me json
and then you realize that actually you
need to do something a little bit more
clever so what you can do now
is you can say i'm going to define a
custom mime type application vendor dot
my api dot version 2 plus json or
vendor my api version 2 plus hal plus
json now the nice thing about this is if
you forgot to do anything special in
version one of your client
your server can go right anyone who asks
for json we know that they're version
one
because if they were version two they'd
know that we changed this thing so
anyone asking for version 2 version 3
version 4 you can handle that with
content negotiation
and again same thing spits back at 200
okay
the third approach you can take here is
you put a custom header in and you just
say get me application json and by the
way x my api version i'm running version
two today what are you running
how do you decide and this you know is
another all of these approaches work
it all hinges on whether version one and
version two are the same resource or not
if you imagine we've got a photograph in
our archive so we've got a picture of
the opera house and sydney harbour
bridge and one client requests that
picture as a png another client requests
it as a jpeg
it's pretty obvious there that what
we're doing is we're taking the same
resource and we're just using a
different representation in each of
those scenarios
whereas you may have a scenario where
customer version one is a completely
different set of data your version two
you rolled out all sorts of compliance
you started doing uh you know deliveries
to the door so suddenly you've got
street addresses you're indexing people
by social security number instead of by
database id
it's a business decision you know you
need to understand your domain and how
you are modeling your domain well enough
to know whether version 1 and version 2
is analogous to the same photograph as a
tifford jpeg or whether version 1
version 2 are actually different
representations because at the end of
the stack there's probably a real person
who hasn't changed it's about what
properties of that person are being
modeled in your system and whether
you've changed that enough that it's
actually a completely different resource
so
if version one and version two represent
same person same resource use content
negotiation same thing different format
if they're completely different
it makes sense to use a different uri
because in this case you have different
resources a resource should be
addressable by the same uri
so different resource different url kind
of makes sense
or there's the actually this is the
point where rest is not the right
solution for our problem we'll just use
a custom header it works you know there
are lots of very successful systems that
use this approach
so that's how you handle it on the
client but what do you do on your server
suddenly you've got a api that needs to
be running version one side by side with
version two
do you branch your code base and have
separate deployment pipelines for v1 and
v2 or do you stick with one code base
and you do all the content negotiation
in code and you have you know like
version two of your controller inherits
from version one of your controller and
this kind of stuff um this is about the
only question i've ever come across in
computer science where the answer is not
it depends i think there is actually a
right answer to this and the right
answer is that you use one code base you
have one deployment pipeline you have
one set of tests you have one single you
know
base of code that represents every api
version that you are still running in
production
and you use something akin to this
because all of these approaches you can
actually map onto the same chunk of code
so what we've got here is a web api
example where we've got a get v2 method
we've got an attribute here that says if
the
client is negotiating on content typing
giving us version two you should hit
this one and we've got a naive route
saying api slash v2 slash profile name
comes here
and this stuff is actually pretty easy
and the nice thing about it is you can
monitor the routes that are being hit
and when you realize that no one is
hitting version one anymore you can go
in and you can just remove it from that
element of the code base the stuff which
is common to version one version two
doesn't end up being two copies of the
same module deployed to two different
places by two different pipelines
okay
so
next bright idea from your your um chief
executive officer someone comes in and
says hey
we hired the cfo's teenage son to build
us a mobile app
because you know and he's like yeah can
i get in the database because i need all
the customer data so i can build this
mobile app using a mobile app building
toolkit that i found in my summer
holidays and someone else is like hey we
just found out that linkbate.com is
asking users to put their password into
their website so they can log in and
scrape all of their friends from our
network
these are real scenarios you know these
are the kind of things you come across
all the time you've got all this data
and other people want to use that data
to do things
and your users maybe have a completely
legitimate reason for wanting to share
that
or your users are being misled they're
being phished they're being misinformed
how do you go in and implement the sort
of security which will protect users
data while still offering them control
over who can do that and what
now
conventionally there's always been this
approach to think of security very much
like if you imagine a bank there's a you
know set of doors
and then there's a public foyer and then
there's a counter and behind that there
are the tellers and behind that there's
a manager's office and behind that
there's a vault
and some people are allowed in the vault
and some people are allowed here it's
this very very kind of atomic level of
security either we trust you or we don't
and if we trust you we trust you with
everything
you know i've worked on systems where
there's a flag on a user that says do
they have delete access
and if they do it means they can delete
anything in the entire system and if
they don't they can't delete anything at
all
which kind of works when you're dealing
with a small number of trusted employees
but for building large-scale distributed
systems where there maybe isn't a
hard line between who's an employee
who's an administrator who's a customer
who's a user
you need to take a much more granular
atomic approach to the way you think
about security
you don't want this idea of there's a
bank vault and you're allowed in and
you're not you want something more akin
to you can get into your safe deposit
box you can get into yours you can get
into yours you can use yours you can't
get into anyone else's
now the protocol that exists for
facilitating this is something called
oauth2 so oauth2 is an authorization
protocol it's not an identification
protocol there is now a thing called
open id connect that sits on top of that
if you're interested in building this
kind of stuff don't
because nobody builds their own crypto
systems and no one should build their
own authentication download identity
server work out how it works and use
that because that solves all of the hard
problems to do with the cryptographic
validity of the the underlying protocols
it's a very nice platform it's very
extensible but effectively what oauth2
does
so
we've got this is our end user we've got
linkbait.com and we've got us we're
startup.com this is our website that's
our api
and link bait wants some data from our
api and the user is happy for this to
happen because the user thinks
linkbait.com is brilliant and they want
to tell all their friends about it
so the first thing that happens the user
goes to link bay and says hey it's me
and link bait goes prove it
go to startup.com and tell them we are
allowed access to your stuff user gets
redirected to startup they log in there
we validate them we send them back a
page
proof that you're you
they put in their credentials
credentials have not been shared with
link bait the credential flow is between
the customer and us
we say yep
gotcha we give them a token
in the browser redirect and say go back
to linkbait.com give them this don't
give them your password that would be
crazy give them this token it's actually
a pair of tokens thing called an access
token and think of a refresh token
the customer gives that token to
link bait link bait sends the token to
our website says is this real
now what it's doing at this point is
it's taking the refresh token i've taken
the code exchange token and it's saying
hey the customer just gave me this can i
have some keys please
and our site is going to respond with
yeah here you go have a set of keys
they can then use those keys to go onto
our api pull data off it
data goes back to link bait dot com
link bait sends that back to the end
user everyone's happy
the best way to think of this token
exchange so the key thing about these
these two keys there's an access key and
there's a refresh key the access key is
like a safe deposit key made out of ice
you can use it unsupervised for about 10
minutes and after that it stops working
now this gives you very powerful
scalability because you don't have to
validate every single request you pick a
time window and you say well
how much damage can someone do with a
key that we know is going to work for 10
minutes but after that it's never going
to work again because an access key
can't be revoked if you're doing stuff
with financial systems or anything
really important there are ways of doing
per request key validation which are
extensions to the protocol but the
underlying principle is we'll give you a
key that will last for five minutes 10
minutes to let you make as many api
calls as you want and then it'll stop
working when it stops working you take
the refresh token
and you go back to us and you say give
me another access token and assuming
that the customer has not logged in and
gone you know settings applications
revoke revoke revoke revoke
that refresh token will succeed we'll
give them another one of these little
melty ice keys that will work for
another 10 minutes and another 10
minutes and another 10 minutes
at no point are the customers
credentials shared with the third party
and beyond that 10 minute expiry window
on the access token
there's no
risk to the customer that their data is
going to be exploited by link bait in a
way that our startup provider can't
control
so
that's oauth2 openid connect we looked
at content negotiation we've looked at
api versioning we've looked at resource
expansion
hopefully all of that stuff
a has been interesting and informative b
has helped some of you maybe understand
a little bit more about what rest is
good at and when rest might not
necessarily be the right answer
we are nearly out of time we have a
couple of minutes for questions
are there any questions
there is a question i want to say
there's a microphone coming around
yeah but it's for the recording
um
in your list of uh
hypermedia style
frameworks that are available did i see
json api or open api or json api
sorry the question is does open api
which is x swagger count in your list
probably i'm not familiar with it
so i don't know
um there is a lot of very very active
development going on around a lot of
these formats open api isn't one i'm
familiar with swagger i have come across
so swagger is basically a way of
it's almost an api design language isn't
it it's a way of defining your endpoints
what they support the nice thing about
swagger is that you can
take a swagger definition you can
generate documentation from it you can
generate dummy clients from it and you
can generate dummy servers from it
because one of the nice things about
that kind of api thing is you can design
the thing and then you can spin up a
dummy implementation that your front-end
team can start calling
and also a service stack which is one of
the net frameworks will actually
generate the other way around you can
generate swagger documentation directly
from the metadata and then you can
generate nice html docs from the swagger
so swagger is another good one it's
worth looking at but in terms of open
api i don't know
ah
so yeah probably then
i don't know if there's anything in
there that's um intrinsically related to
hyper media but i'll certainly go and
look it up so
any other questions yes
for the versioning thing
how do you actually define a version for
an api like if an api has said
representing like three different
resources today yep so it's possible
that i add a new resource tomorrow yep
or just one of the resources has changed
uh properties or something like that so
it's the enter api version or it's just
like the profile that is version but the
friends are not version and
the canonical way of doing this is that
somebody is retrieving slash profile
and one morning they look at the lynx
collection and in links collection there
is an href for version 2 of that profile
hypermedia is an incredibly flexible
pattern that you can use for all sorts
of things and as well as saying hey this
profile's got friends this profile's got
status updates you can say this profile
has a newer api representation available
so you can use the same hypermedia
patterns and the thing about that is
because you're not changing anything
because you're just adding new fields to
it you won't break clients by adding new
elements to the links collection that's
available on a resource
and so that gives you a way of
gracefully notifying clients that a new
representation of something is available
it's also an argument in favor of
doing sort of either content negotiation
style stuff as opposed to just saying
there is now version two of our api
which completely deprecates version one
you can actually go with the idea of
having versioned resources which conform
to content negotiation instead of saying
hey where said v1 in all your web
addresses before put v2 in there now
does that answer the question
partly
that's fine i mean the other thing is
that's more of it i guess the discussion
is
uh have you seen a resistance step
to do this proper way of rest was i have
to huge amount of resistance from
let's say i'm doing an api my clients
didn't want all this thing they said
they're all crap
i don't i don't need these things
bloating it i have no reason for all
these links href blah blah blah they
just rejected this uh this concert they
wanted to go to page equal to five yeah
the clients didn't want it i like paying
you
well it's my own company so
they're all working together but they
didn't want the api people to give them
apis like that
so
just do the rest of friends you can try
and educate them or you can accept that
they're paying the bills and you do what
they want
it's the great trade-off of anyone who
goes we don't like your solution you
know
um i don't have a magic bullet answer
for that you know i think understand it
understand the costs understand the
trade-offs and then try and reach an
informed consensus among the people who
have a stake in the thing
so
any other questions
grand well thank you very very much for
coming along taking the time to listen
um my name's dylan i'm on twitter as
dylan beatty um i'm on email dylan at
dylanbeaty.net if any of you want to
follow up on anything or talk about any
of this stuff further um i'm around all
week and the one wearing a big stupid
cowboy hat so come and say hello if you
have any more questions or anything you
want to talk about
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
the conference